[Music]
we're going on YouTube
now everybody at a certain point in
their life has gone to the issue of acne
pimples face loves but pepperoni thick
what pebbles I hate Oh
pimples are probably one of the worst
things that has ever happened to the
human race I don't even know why we got
them they serve no purpose uh you might
as well put a sign on your forehead that
says what y'all still run away nah [ __ ]
it that's cool whatever no [ __ ] it I
just touch myself what
well my pimply faced people I'm here let
you know that you are not alone when it
comes to the battle with acne a pink
bracelet on the hill breast cancer
awareness doesn't affect you alone
ladies me too so you already know what
it is LG up any let's get it let's go
you pitbull ow I hate pimples what is it
that every time you got to go do
something important a fever will pop out
on the point of your face this sticks
out the mouth it's like that beautiful
definition over [ __ ] the [ __ ] up your
life
damn I got a fine ass date tonight go
get me some candy
hey and this is your pimple speaking no
pee for you pimple on your face all the
worst because that is all people look at
and I don't blame you because it's
almost impossible not to I do the same
thing I freeze up like I just witnessed
a murder some chick hump what's up what
you looking at man know what Dawg know
how I would in my family puts up with
some pimples or pimples pickles I uh
that mess is a holy baking for judgment
I when you got that fat-ass scribble on
your face but they act like they didn't
see it at all and when you confront them
their voices all high-pitched and [ __ ]
hey what's up dawg god damn No hey it's
the pimple huh Oh what now I'm gonna
good here people you know yeah kiss me
with over you who have never had a
pimple in your life go but if you have
never had a pimp
or any acne problem of your life let me
let you in on something is something
that's very hard to deal with it
obviously affects your self-esteem
because it's the first thing you
advertise to people you can have like
the finest body on earth but it doesn't
matter because if it looks like you fell
into a hot ass out of butt-ass ugly
it don't mean muffin nothing nothing
muffin that's a muffin that goddamn I'm
fat get a little bit of advice to don't
tell people with acne that if they just
watch their face it'll all go away if it
was that simple don't you think
everybody will be doing it [ __ ] they're
stupid why don't you just shut your face
and get your life together that's like
asking a homeless man why you hungry dog
cuz I got no food we'll go buy some to
eat a [ __ ] come here so extending look
I know it seems at times that I have
nice skin but I don't it's just the
camera and the lighting and you know
I'll be honest with you I told you guys
before I'm a hater anybody glass nice
skin I want to slap the [ __ ] outta
Kristen
every time I look at you I want to jump
kick you in the face with some cleats
chris is not good friends we're actually
working on a web series you get it so
for those you guys are like oh don't
make fun of Kristen shut the hell I'll
do whatever want he's my friend to slap
him in the face if you're a young kid
and you don't have acne don't make fun
of another kid who has acne because it
is a very sensitive subject it'll all
come back to you because I remember when
my brother had his mouth of a pea and I
call that full pizza face
then he'll it I'll broke out two I was
like Quasimodo's butt cheeks y'all let
me get that one big-ass pimple on a ski
right no just me this is awkward
if later on tonight I asked you to be my
girlfriend
right yeah a car alarm is going off
right now
hurry up in rabaa it's about
[ __ ] time so somebody giggling
out there yeah we should be down to
taking their horn right now like early
in the morning tomorrow
what happened six Shiva somebody just
went in duty just unflushed right now
that's cool whatever